an in desperate need of healing turn it
down a few minutes ago Annabel read the
story of neiman the aramean general
naman was a strong and successful man he
was great at his job his father loved
him he was used to accomplishing what he
set out to do in professional terms his
life was a series of victories but naman
was suffering from a shameful sickness
and this sickness was slowly and
steadily consuming him he was so
desperate to be healed from his leprosy
that he left behind his family and
everything he knew and he took his life
savings and travel to a foreign country
to seek a cure after traveling across
arum and israel and visiting a foreign
palace but he has a very awkward
conversation with the king naman finally
gets the message he's been waiting for
the Prophet Elisha sends him some simple
clear instructions explaining what he
needs to do to be healed wash seven
times in the Jordan River but then
instead of heading to the river naman
turns away after all that the years of
suffering the months of withing at the
mercy of hope and fear the long journey
the stressful encounter with royalty
when Amon finally gets the prophetic
prescription for a healing bath he says
no so here's what I've been thinking
about this week why was naman so
resistant to healing why did he turn
away why would someone in such desperate
need of healing turn it down these
questions matter because at times all of
us are in need of healing and at times
all of us find healing hard to accept
and our opening hymn we sang commie
sinners poor and needy weak and wounded
sick and sore this hymn is addressed to
us some of us are poor in economic terms
some of us are not
but at times all of us feel like we need
more than we have like naman we might be
strong and successful but sometimes we
feel weak sometimes when we think about
midterms and papers and lsat sand mcats
and field exams and dissertations in the
job market and the economy we feel like
we simply aren't strong enough to do
what we're expected to do sometimes self
doubt and fear eat away at us like
leprosy like naman we all have wounds
and sores we've been wounded by a
culture that tells us that our worth
depends on our achievements that our
grades matter that our bodies are not
beautiful enough that our race or gender
is inferior or that our sexuality is a
sin some of us have been wounded by
bullying some of us are hexic we live
with the ever-present absence of a loved
one we lost some of us are lonely some
of us are just numb like naman whose
nerve endings were damaged by his own
asst some of us are suffering from an
inability to feel we might be suffering
physically mentally emotionally
spiritually or all of the above but
often we find it hard to accept the help
that we need so today I'm going to talk
about what name and story can teach us
about resistance to healing about why do
you refuse help when it's offered and
what we can do to start allowing healing
into our lives and thinking about the
obstacles name and encountered and the
obstacles he created we can learn
lessons about what to do and what not to
do and hopefully for those of us who
tend to be resistant to healing naman
can help us learn to get out of our own
way and begin to accept the healing
that's available to us here and now
lesson number one when you're looking
for personal healing don't go talk to
the king the King can't help you for
some kinds of problems it's great to go
straight to the top
sometimes it's appropriate to sign a
petition to president obama to make an
appointment with President 11 or to send
an email to police chief lionel higgins
some problems do need government
solutions for example as we learned in
another part of the book of kings if you
and this other women you know are
fighting over a baby boy and each of you
swears that the baby is yours and
neither of you is willing to back down
but you know that you're right King
Solomon is definitely the person you
need to talk to he can take care of that
situation for you but the need for
personal healing is not a problem for
Kings to solve even in an age of
government health care people who are
ready need to get care at a hospital not
a capital if you need mental healing you
need to go to a mental health
professional and if you need spiritual
healing you need to go somewhere where
you can get spiritual help naman needed
the kind of healing that only a prophet
could provide he went to Israel in the
first place because an Israeli girl who
worked at his house told him about the
amazing profit there who could heal him
but the first way that naman resisted
his own healing was to go to see a king
instead like many of us naman avoided
spiritual solutions because he was more
comfortable dealing with things that
were familiar power dynamics he was used
to navigating transactions that fit
easily into a sense of how the world
worked he liked to feel in control of
the situation he had worked closely with
the King back in Aaron so when he went
to visit the king of Israel he could
stay in his professional persona he
could talk about healing as if it were a
political problem or a business
transaction the only problem was that
the King had no idea how to heal him
when we need spiritual healing we need
to make sure we're looking in the right
places lesson number two healing isn't
always a spectacular and instantaneous
event don't expect an earth-shattering
moment in which he show up and someone
does something to
and suddenly everything's okay even in
the Bible healing is not magic after the
King can't help him neiman does go to
the Prophet Elisha but when Elijah sends
out a servant to tell him to watch seven
times in the river naman becomes angry
and goes away saying I thought that for
me he would surely come out and stand
and call on the name of the Lord his God
and a wave his hand over the spot and
cured the leprosy naman is frustrated
for many reasons he wants a dramatic
encounter with a powerful person but
instead he gets a message from a servant
he wants a magical moment in which oh I
show waves his arm like Harry Potter
waving a wand but instead he is told to
go take a bath he wants ceiling to
happen right away but instead he is told
that there's more that has to happen
first Elijah's offer of healing doesn't
fit neimans pre-existing idea of what
healing is supposed to look like it's
not glamorous it's not exciting it's a
little humbling so named and turns it
down lessons number three and four don't
expect the healing process to be
convenient and don't wait to do it until
it makes sense after turning down
hellacious prescription of bathing in
the Jordan naman starts complaining are
not abana and fire fire the rivers of
Damascus better than all the waters of
Israel he asks can I not wash them them
and be clean Bailey in the Jordan River
is inconvenient and it doesn't make
sense logically there's no reason to
bathe in the Jordan you can take about
anywhere name is probably thinking if I
can't get healing directly from the King
and if I can't have the dramatic magical
America like rave at least I want to get
healed close to home in a river I know
and like I think neimans response gives
us some insight into some of the ways we
might resist healing and some of the
excuses we might use to keep it at bay I
know I can relate to name in here I can
easily imagine saying
I want my healing process to make total
sense to me and ideally I'd like it to
happen in my neighborhood and if I can't
have it on those terms I don't want it
at all unfortunately as name and
discovers we can't always have hailing
on our own terms and at this point in
the story it looks like he's settling
for no healing at all what's the number
five listen to your community it's at
exactly this point the name and servants
decide to stage an intervention and the
story ceases to head towards tragedy and
takes a turn towards the miraculous name
and servants a father if the Prophet had
commanded you to do something difficult
but you not have done it how much more
when all you said to you was wash and be
clean this summer I taught a writing
class at the med school my students were
pre-med students working on personal
statements for the medical applications
and their first assignment was to write
about a time when they were a patient it
turns out that pre-med students are
often terrible patients they are grated
doing hard things like organic chemistry
but when they have the flu and their
doctor tells them to do something easy
like rust and sleep and drink fluids
they say no way I am going to power it
through the flu one of my students were
at a time and she was trying to power
through the classes within 103 degree
fever and a roommates had to sit her
down and say look you're sick it's time
for you to go to bed and drink some tea
sometimes that are insisting on doing
things the hard way and trying to heal
ourselves through sheer willpower and
stand that we need to stop and listen to
our community the people around us who
care about our well-being sometimes when
we're resisting healing they can help us
see what we need to do which brings us
to lesson number six embrace the healing
power of ritual thankfully name and
story doesn't end with his roof
ulta babe eventually naman listens to
the people around him and decides to
give healing a chance he goes to the
Jordan River and he walks in and he
washes himself and then he does it again
and again and again and again and again
and again and then he looks down at
himself and he sees that his flesh is
restored and he is clean ritual is a
powerful thing you don't have to
understand it for it to work all you
have to do is choose to participate when
our desire to maintain control can hold
us back when we're demanding
instantaneous solutions participating in
ritual can help to make us whole we can
believe in ritual even when we can't
believe in anything else through
participation and repetition we can
bypass our insistence on intellectual
understanding and allow God's grace to
heal us very healed through the water of
baptism the bread and wine of communion
the weekly rituals of our worship
together as a community and our
individual worship with just us and God
but we're also healed through quotidian
rituals we perform every day if we're
suffering from perfectionism then every
time we show up to take a midterm or
open up our laptop to write a paper we
can imagine that we are walking to the
bank of the River Jordan and gently
immersing ourselves and it's healing
streams if we are crippled by our fear
of future then every time we send out a
job application or show up at an
interview we can think about how the
waters of the Jordan are washing our
fears away name and washed in the Jordan
7 times in the Bible 7 is a special
number sometimes it means 7 sometimes it
means infinity majitha said we should
forgive people seventy times seven he
didn't mean that we should forgive them
for
90 times he meant we should just keep on
forgiving healing rituals are part of a
lifelong process that needs to keep on
happening like meals and showers these
rituals of healing need to be part of
our daily lives our seventh and last
lesson of the day is that praise is part
of the process name and story doesn't
end when he walks out of the river with
healthy skin it doesn't end with him
heading home and living exactly like he
did before instead it ends with him
saying from now on I'm gonna praise God
neimans guardedness has been transformed
to gratitude he even asked for some dirt
to take home from the place where he was
healed so he can always remember what
happened to him in Israel he is never
going to forget what God did for him
sisters and brothers the good news of
name and story is that healing is real
it was real for him and it is real for
us the challenge of neimans story is
that sometimes our defense mechanisms
can prevent us from receiving healing
when it is offered to us but name and
story teaches us that we don't need to
feel ready we don't need to wait or get
angry or turn away we don't need money
or power we don't need to be worthy we
just need to listen to our friends and
participate in the healing process in
the words of the hymn let not conscience
make you linger nor fitness fondly dream
all the fitness Christ required is to
feel your need of him let's venture on
God like naman let's finally set aside
our fears and hesitations our need for
control and let's learn to embrace the
healing that's ours and then let's spend
our lives and gratitude and praise Amen